e no Brasil de cada 10 pessoas oito
possuem ansiedade financeira se não é
você é alguém que está do seu lado
se alguém que tem problemas para dormir
preocupado com dinheiro que sente até
taquicardia quando chega a fatura do
cartão de crédito
a ansiedade financeira é uma das
consequências do Mau uso do dinheiro
e a gente vai para escola aprende estuda
para ter uma profissão para ganhar nosso
dinheiro
é mas em momento algum a gente aprende a
usar esse dinheiro é como nos contos de
fada se casaram e foram felizes para
sempre
eu só esqueci de contar que um
relacionamento para dar certo precisa de
atenção precisa entender que tem altos e
baixos que tem desafios precisa cuidar
de um relacionamento todo dia para que
ele dê certo com o dinheiro também assim
o dinheiro é um relacionamento de longo
prazo
e esse aí na foto à esquerda de chapéu
Sou Eu em 2008 tinha 26 anos de idade
solteiro sem filhos dinheiro para mim
era só para mim não tinha muita
complexidade para lidar com dinheiro aí
você olha essa foto viu fazendo coisa na
ponte do Brooklin intensa esse aí tá
muito bem né de Pato eu tava muito bem
tinha juntado o meu dinheiro comprar a
passagem ido reservado o hotel curtir
Dias Incríveis ali naquela cidade fui
para bares restaurantes lojas Me
empolguei empolguei e perdi a mão
eu perdi a mão quando voltei para casa
é uma tragédia a fatura do meu cartão de
crédito em dólares e aparecia cara em
Reais uma tragédia eu fiquei os meses
seguintes parcelando essa fatura do meu
cartão de crédito parece pouco mas para
mim foi péssimo eu me senti muito mal
eu não fiz nada durante meses parei tudo
com muito juros mas paguei
se você já se sentiu assim
E por que que será que isso acontece
e depois essa experiência que o
endividamento o mundo deu algumas voltas
eu fui trabalhar com que
em 2014 e fui trabalhar com educação
financeira
o rodeio Brasil e o mundo desenvolvendo
projetos e implementando projetos
avaliando projetos e buscando entender
como as pessoas se relacionam com o
dinheiro o que funciona mais que
funciona - quais são os desafios das
pessoas com o dinheiro
e depois fui fazer um mestrado que
estudei 400 pessoas endividadas
e com essa experiência profissional e a
experiência acadêmica
e eu descobri gente que nossa relação
com dinheiro ela não é racional como
gente gostaria de pensar relação com
dinheiro ela é emocional não é só quem
ganha pouco que têm problemas
financeiros muita gente ganha muito
Oi tá endividado rotativo do cartão de
crédito sofrendo então o que que faz uma
pessoa que ganha bem estar endividada e
uma pessoa que ninguém é tão bem ou para
investir consegui conquistar os seus
objetivos financeiros o ponto é não
quanto você ganha mas sim como você usa
o seu dinheiro como você gasta o seu
dinheiro Esse é um ponto chave e o
dinheiro mesmo apenas uma número na sua
conta bancária ou um pedaço de papel
o dinheiro para atrelada muito
sentimentos poder auto-estima a
segurança parece que o dinheiro é uma
ponte a gente receber amor das pessoas
ser visto ser notado e muitas às vezes
pode parecer duro isso mas muitas das
vezes as coisas que a gente compra são
uma tentativa de projetar uma imagem
Nossa
a elite gostaria de ter Então por essas
e outras razões
a gastar o dinheiro errado
E se rolar financeiramente ficar
endividado
e é muito normal é muito comum
e agora
e por mais que essa nossa relação com
dinheiro seja conturbada e mal resolvida
a gente vai ter que um cara ela
e a nossa relação com o dinheiro não tem
divórcio
o e nunca vai ter se a gente não
consegue dar conta se a gente não
conseguir levar nossa vida financeira
e de forma positiva alguém vai ter que
ajudar a gente nossos pais nossos filhos
alguém na nossa família algum amigo o
dinheiro é um grande Tabu é aquele
assunto que a gente não quer falar
e todo mundo lida com dinheiro todos os
dias mas mesmo assim pouca gente fala
sobre dinheiro
e você sabe quanto que os seus amigos
ganham
o quanto que seus colegas de trabalho
ganho e os seus pais eles falavam eles
falam para você quando que eles ganham
provavelmente não
e agora não falar sobre dinheiro não vai
fazer seus problemas financeiros
desaparecerem pelo contrário os casais
não se comunicam sobre dinheiro e as
brigas por conta de dinheiro são a maior
causa de divórcio
o amor causa de insônia é financeira
também uma em cada três pessoas não
consegue dormir direito por causa das
preocupações financeiras foi milhões e
milhões de brasileiros rolando no
travesseiro todas as noites e não é para
fazer sexo gertraf tantos problemas
Morais talvez porque ele quer traduzir
qualidade em quantidade
e talvez perguntar para uma pessoa
quanto que ela ganha seja um tabu você
já até ofensivo porque você tá
indiretamente questionando o valor dessa
pessoa
a ansiedade financeira é uma inimiga
silenciosa
nós precisamos falar sobre a ansiedade
financeira porque ela pode ser um
gatilho muito grande para outros
problemas não falar sobre isso é como
colocar pólvora uma bomba que está
prestes a explodir e essa bomba é a
saúde mental das pessoas bom então como
melhorar a nossa relação com o dinheiro
eu vou falar três coisas aqui que você
precisa aprender uma toma mais tempo mas
é muito eficiente principalmente no
longo prazo as outras duas são mais
práticas e fáceis de implementar
a primeira coisa aprenda sobre você
e a qualidade da sua vida financeira não
vai se resolver se você apenas aprender
sobre questões técnicas sobre dinheiro
na verdade essa qualidade financeira a
muito relacionada às suas crenças sobre
dinheiro
e procure identificar essas crianças as
nossas crianças financeiras são formadas
principalmente na infância e são
inconscientes e mesmo que os seus pais
nunca temos falado sobre dinheiro para
você tudo que você viveu na sua infância
que está relacionado a esse assunto você
guardou seus pais brigavam muito sobre
dinheiro
e eles pesquisavam bastante antes de
comprar alguma coisa comparavam preço Ou
eles fazem extravagance cê consumiam
mais do que eles deviam Não importa se
você tinha muito ou pouco a forma como
você viveu seus primeiros anos de vida
são determinantes na maneira como você
enxerga o dinheiro
o dinheiro na mão é vendaval o dinheiro
é raiz de todo mal essas são apenas
algumas crianças que nós cultivamos e
perpetuamos sem nem mesmo entender o com
prejudiciais elas são para nós mesmos
então busca identificar as suas crenças
mundo é cheio de ofertas tentadoras nós
somos acessados o tempo inteiro para
consumir a gente caia nessa tentação a
gente tá cavando o nosso abismo e
financeiro passa coisas práticas para se
ajudar para que você precisa de 235
cartões de crédito para que você precisa
parcelar alguma coisa em 12 vezes se não
é urgente Imagina você juntar o dinheiro
poupar o dinheiro e comprar à vista
ainda negociando um desconto Imagina
você não de ver nenhuma parcela para
nada no futuro é terceira coisa é
É sobre o dinheiro que fica essencial
aprender a poupar EA investir seu
dinheiro
e a maioria das pessoas fala que vai
investir que vai poupar assim que
consegui fazer sobrar algum dinheiro no
fim do mês na prática o que que acontece
a recebe o seu dinheiro paga suas contas
faz as coisas que ela quer as coisas que
aparecem
um animal Chega no fim do mês
e não consegue Papá não é então você não
paga a conta de água de luz e internet
paga uma conta para você mesmo no futuro
o pai do seu eu do Futuro paga essa
conta assim que você receber o seu
dinheiro imagina mês a mês ano a ano
você pagando essa conta para você mesmo
10 15 anos quanto dinheiro você consegue
poupar essa mensagem terra é simples
para você conseguir fazer o seu dinheiro
sobrar e investir olha ansiedade
financeira ela pode ser reduzida
drasticamente se você começa a organizar
o seu dinheiro
Bom dia que vem depois que você vence
ansiedade financeira o bem-estar
financeiro
o bem-estar financeiro é você se sentir
à vontade com a sua assinatura seguro
com as faxinas é você conseguir um raça
as contas pagar suas contas aproveitar o
presente ter dinheiro para o futuro
poupar para o seu futuro e buscar
realizar os seus sonhos sonhar planejar
e conquistar esses sonhos você já se
imaginou assim
bom então dê o seu primeiro passo para
sua educação financeira Se comprometa
com a sua educação financeira Eu garanto
para você que é mais fácil do que você
pensa